[Musik]
du musst durchhalten sagen Sie ihn
zuerst schafften sie es nicht Mohammed
zu befreien aus dem was man seinen zu
Hause war trinken stärken und Zeit zu
gewinnen bis zu seiner Rettung für ihn
und all die anderen die aus den Trümmern
befreit wurden muss das nicht heißen
dass überleben die Krankenhäuser sind
entweder zerstört oder völlig überlastet
etwas Warmes zu bekommen ist da schon
ein Glück
und weil wir mit jedem Tag mehr das
Ausmaß dieser Naturkatastrophe absehen
senden wir auch heute ein zdf-spezial
guten Abend
nachdem was die Erde anrichtete ist nun
die Zeit der größte Gegner 65 Stunden
sind bereits vergangen lange haben die
mehr als 60.000 die gekommen sind und
mit anzupacken nicht mehr um Leben zu
retten noch aber gelingt es und stellt
damit dieser immensen Zahl der Opfer es
sind mehr als 11.000 einen Willen und
Zuversicht entgegen beginnen wir in der
Türkei wenn ja Berger auf fast den Tag
zusammen
ein Haufen Schutt ist auf das einzige
was von Häusern und Wohnblöcken nach den
Erdbeben noch übrig geblieben ist bei
eisigen Temperaturen suchen die Menschen
Zuflucht in Zeltlagern im eigenen Auto
oder wie hier in diabakir in einer
Moschee ihnen fehlt es am nötigsten
wir haben kein Wasser kein Essen einfach
nichts ich will nur Hilfe bekommen
nichts weiter wie ich unterkomme ist mir
egal Hauptsache meine Kinder sind in
Sicherheit
im Schutt versuchen Helfer Tag und Nacht
Überlebende zu finden mit schwerem Gerät
mit Suchhunden viel zu oft aber können
nur noch Leichen geborgen werden
und doch gibt es Momente wie diesen hier
in Hatay nach 52 Stunden unter den
Trümmern wird eine 23-jährige gerettet
längst sind nicht mehr nur türkische
Helfer an der Bergung beteiligt Hilfe
kommt aus aller Welt zum Beispiel aus
Israel Taiwan Griechenland und Italien
dieses Team der spanischen Feuerwehr
sucht mit Hilfe von Kameras nach
Lebenszeichen unter dem Schutz
auch chinesische sucht Teams sind mit
ihrem Equipment angekommen und selbst
die kriegsgebeutelte Ukraine schickt
Bergungsteams in das Krisengebiet
in unserer Situation hilft uns die ganze
Welt da können wir doch jetzt nicht
einfach daneben stehen und nicht helfen
so gut wir können
Verletzte aus den Erdbebengebieten
werden inzwischen auch nach Istanbul
geflogen damit die Erdbebenopfer
medizinisch versorgt werden können
mehrere Flugzeuge sind dort bereits
gelandet und die Patienten in
Krankenhäuser gebracht worden
eigentlich in Wesel am Sonntag ist sie
zur Familie gereist in das Dorf Erde
wenige Stunden später kam das Beben
guten Abend
als wir kurz vor der Sendung
telefonierten wurden gerade fünf
Familienmitglieder beerdigt hatten sie
überhaupt schon Zeit zu trauern
nein nein
das ist von ihrem Dorf stehen geblieben
gibt es noch ein Dach über den Kopf
Strom Wasser
kein Strom
nicht sehr gleichen kein Dach vor allem
die Menschen die hier noch überlebt
haben sind auf der Straße gibt es
Hilfslieferungen die sehr erreicht haben
also bis heute ist nichts angekommen
aber wir erwarten erst einmal ja also ab
morgen Mittag erwarten wir die nächste
also die erste Lieferung aber auch von
unserer Seite also nichts
außerhalb sondern rein privat das heißt
es gibt noch keine offiziellen
Hilfslieferung es gibt nur private Hilfe
verwandte Freunde
genau alles vergleichbare Sachen genau
wer ist dabei
die großen Organisationen die gehen
erstmal in die Großstädte wo sowieso
schon
nahezu genug Möglichkeiten bestehen die
Dörfer sind da ein bisschen im
Hintergrund geblieben wer ist dabei
ihnen wer was können sie momentan
überhaupt tun sind noch Menschen
verschüttet
ja es sind noch
hier die ist persönlich keine katzliche
okay also drei bis vier Leute sind noch
verborgen wie geht das
wie geht es ihrer Familie
also teilweise sind wir froh überlebt zu
haben auf der anderen Seite wissen wir
nicht wie es weitergeht also für uns
klar wir werden morgen oder die nächsten
Tage abreißen
baldmöglich aber die anderen die werden
halt hier zurück bleiben das heißt sie
wollen auch dieses Dorf verlassen ist
das überhaupt noch eine Heimat für die
Familie
ich denke nein
also hier ist keiner mehr der
zurückkommen möchte ist das einfach
keiner da
danke für diese Schilderung danke dass
ich Zeit genommen haben und wenn es ein
kleiner Trost ist im Moment denken viele
an sie danke schön
vielen Dank
schauen wir nun nach Syrien da kommt zu
diesem Unglück noch der Bürgerkrieg
hinzu von der ohnehin maroden
Infrastruktur im Norden ist nicht mehr
viel übrig die Straße vom einzigen
offenen Grenzübergang von der Türkei
nach Syrien hinein wurde beschädigt die
wenigen Hilfslieferungen die durchkommen
brauchen noch länger oder stecken
komplett fest das ersatzregime
beschuldigt den Westen die Sanktionen
würden die Rettungsmaßnahmen erschweren
das Auswärtige Amt in Berlin aber
stellte nochmals klar Lebensmittel
Medikamente und schweres Gerät sind
nicht sanktioniert guline
Harim eine Kleinstadt im Bezirk Idlib
Nordwest Syrien
Einwohner haben freiwillige
zusammengerufen um am Tag 3 nach dem
Beben die wahrscheinlich letzten
Überlebenden zu retten selbst hier im
Kriegsgebiet wo sie Leid und Schmerz
seit Jahren kennen sind sie überwältigt
vom Ausmaß der Zerstörung
wir bitten die Vereinten Nationen wir
bitten die arabischen Länder und
Bergungsgerät zu schicken wir haben
wirklich nur wenig Ausrüstung hier wie
Sie sehen können reicht es nicht aus
immer wenn ein Kind überlebt hat jubeln
sie und geht ein Raunen durch die Menge
[Musik]
zehn Kilometer weiter in Sanin eine
Mutter versucht ihre Tochter zu trösten
nachdem der Vater vor ihren Augen tot
geworden wurde
oh Gott ich hoffe da drin gibt es noch
lebende es sind mehr als 150 Seelen in
diesem Gebäude gefangen sagt Abu
Mohammed die sieben Angehörige vermisst
34 Tote liegen im kleinen provisorischen
Krankenhaus der Ortschaft 400 Verletzte
mussten sie bislang hier behandeln sagen
sie
für einen am ganzen Leib zitternden Mann
der gerade geborgen wurde gibt es kein
Bett mehr
seine Brüder versuchen ihn zu beruhigen
am Tag 3 ist in der oppositionsentklave
in Nordwest Syrien noch immer keine
Hilfe angekommen
luckily today wir hörten heute
glücklicherweise dass die Straße zum
Grenzübergang geöffnet werden konnte so
dass wir ab morgen hoffentlich die
Grenzregion erreichen können und die
Menschen dort
Aleppo im vom Assad-Regime
kontrollierten Gebiet in den betroffenen
Städten hier haben nach
Regierungsangaben fast 300.000 Menschen
ihre Häuser verlassen müssen Damaskus
fragt nun auch die EU um Hilfe an
verbunden bin ich jetzt mit Oliver
hochredes dem Leiter der Nothilfe
Malteser International sie sind gestern
in Köln gestartet heute morgen in der
Türkei angekommen und jetzt den Kilis
nahe der syrischen Grenze was sagen
Ihnen die Eindrücke die sie seither
gesammelt haben
ja guten Tag erstmal ja die Eindrücke
sind natürlich dramatisch wie die Lage
wir sehen viele Menschen die auf den
Straßen hier sich eine Unterkunft
eingerichtet haben wir sehen
traumatisierte Menschen wir sehen
Menschen die zwei Tage nach dem Erdbeben
teilweise sprachlos sind um Hilfe auch
bitten wir haben Menschen gesehen die
auf LKWs sich Unterkünfte provisorische
eingerichtet haben das sind schon
schwere Bilder die wir auch hier sehen
vor Ort das Assad Regime in der maskus
sagt die westlichen Sanktionen gegen
Syrien würden Hilfslieferungen
erschweren stimmt das aus ihrer Sicht
nun es gibt die Möglichkeiten ja auch
über die Grenzen Hilfe zu leisten wir
selber haben in Syrien mit syrischen
Partnern sehr vielen Jahren Projekte im
Gesundheitsbereich wir arbeiten den
Krankenhäusern deshalb versorgen
verwundete derzeit verstärkt natürlich
seit dem Erdbeben in den letzten zweiter
Tagen sind es über 100 Operation die
wird auch durchgeführt haben mit den
syrischen Ärzten vor Ort das ist worauf
wir uns derzeit konzentrieren aber
sicher ist dass die Notlage in Syrien
natürlich sehr sehr groß ist auch wegen
des Erdbebens in Syrien tobt zudem er
auch seit 12 Jahren der Bürger kriegt
die Kinder dort kennen gar nichts
anderes jetzt noch diese Katastrophe was
können sie da ausrichten
na das sind natürlich traumatisierte
Kinder die haben in ihrem Leben wenn sie
jetzt zurückdenken die letzten 12 Jahre
und nie was anderes gesehen die Leben in
den Traumata einmacht dem anderen sie
sind im Krieg aufgewachsen jetzt kommt
die Naturkatastrophe noch mit dazu das
ist schwer teilweise in Worte zu fassen
wir sind sehr froh dass wir gute Ärzte
gute auch Psychologen
die dass das geben aber das ist
natürlich eine eine Menge Lage die sehr
sehr schwierig ist und für Kinder
natürlich eine Herausforderung ist die
schwer zu verkraften ist das sind ja
große Herausforderung was können sie
denn da überhaupt tun gehen Sie jetzt
kurzfristig vor oder haben Sie auch
schon einen mittelfristigen
langfristigen Planung zu helfen
da wir helfen ja in Syrien seit du mehr
zehn Jahren auch vor allem
Gesundheitsbereich jetzt kommt die
Katastrophe natürlich noch dazu das
heißt wir werden jetzt die
lebenswirkende Maßnahmen erhöhen wir
werden versuchen Medikamente nach wie
vor auch in an die Krankenhäuser zu
entzünden jetzt sind natürlich Zelte
notwendig es ist bitterkalt auch in
Syrien sind eisige Temperaturen die
Menschen sind ja teilweise sehr gut
untergebracht da geht es jetzt auch
darum die Menschen noch Decken und
Heizgeräte zu bringen und das ist eine
große Herausforderung mit der Zeit für
uns alle danke dass Sie sich die Zeit
genommen haben Oliver
danke schön
und weil die Leitungen in diese Region
nicht zuverlässig funktionieren haben
wir beide Gespräche dieser Sendung kurz
vorher aufgezeichnet
wenn sie den Menschen in Syrien und der
Türkei helfen wollen können Sie spenden
beim Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
IBAN
de6500 400
600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Türkei Syrien das können Sie aber auch
in Ruhe nachlesen unter spendenpunkten
zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf Seite 890
die Europäische Union plant für Anfang
März
um internationale Hilfe für die Türkei
und Syrien zu mobilisieren das kündigte
heute kommissionspräsidentin von der
Leyen an beide Länder könnten auf die EU
zählen
das war unser zdf-spezial hier im
Programm geht es jetzt weiter mit Hotel
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]